اولا الموضوع ما عنا من الاردن الدكتور في
المستشفى الملكي في لندن احمد سلمان
المشتت اهلا بك استاذ دكتور احمد همم يوم
28 هو راس السنه الصينيه الجديده يعني همم
مع هذه الاعداد من الصينيين الذين يعودون
الى بلادهم بعد سنوات من همم الحرمان من
زياره اهاليهم
والزيارات المنتظره الداخليه بين الارياف
والمدن بمناسبه هذه
العيد متى همم على الصحه وعلى انتشار
الفيروس كرونه تحديدا
مرحبا بكم طبعا هناك موجه انتشار جديده في
الصين بدات منذ منتصف شهر ديسمبر الماضي
همم وكانت هناك قفزه كبيره في الاعداد
المشكله الحقيقيه في الصين هو ان البيانات
مثل ما قالت تقرير اا تقريركم عن البيانات
التي تاتي من الصين حول اعداد الاصابات
وحول اعداد الوفياته بيانات غير دقيقه
وغير صحيحه ايضا وهناك عدم ثقه بهذه
البيانات من قبل الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وهذا هذه
الحقيقه ثابته حتى منذ عام 2020 عندما
بدات الجائحه وكانت الصين هي مصدر هذه
الجائحه السياسه الصينيه مع الكوبيد
السياسي الداخليه سياسه غير فعالا واثبت
عدم فعاليتها منذ عام 2020 هذه السياسه
التي المواطنين العزل القاسي والعزل
الكبير همم سياسه غير ناجحه همم ولم تاتي
ثمارها ابدا والدليل ان الصين تشهد دائما
همم تكرر موجات الكوبونات
الذي يشير اليه كثير من المراقبين انه عدد
الصينيين الذين طعموا بالقاحات المضاده
لفيروس كورونا عدد قليل مقارنه مع همم عدد
السكان في البلاد لكن المتحور المنتشر حتى
الان في الصين هو متحور همم اوميكرون وهو
متحور يعني همم لقح هذا همم اغلبيه سكان
الدول العالم متى تدعيه الاخرى يعني في
حال لم يكن القلق من نقل هذا المتحور الى
باقي دول العالم ما تدعيه اخرى ربما في
حال عوده هؤلاء الصينيين الى دول الاقامه
هل من همم ما خوف ايضا بخصوص الادويه
والاقنعه في حال تم استهلاكها بشكل كبير
في الصين
طبعا بالتاكيد هناك كبير من انتشار هذه
المتحورات وهذه المتحورات الموجوده في
الصين بالمناسبه هي موجوده في اوروبا في
بريطانيا وفي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهناك تقارير في هذا الاسبوع عن وجود
متحور الاكس اكس دي 1 5 بريطانيا المتحده
الامريكيه ايضا وهذه المتحورات لا تخضع
للمناعه الحاليه وتسبب انتشار كبير للمرض
ولكنها لا تسبب امراض خطيره ايضا خصوصا
عند الاشخاص الذين تلقوا اللقاح ايضا
البيانات الوارده من الصين حول اعداد
الملقحين حول فعاليه اللقاحات في منع
تكرار الاصابات غير دقيقه ولا نعرف الكثير
عنها المهم هذه الاجراءات التي تقوم بها
الصين للحد من انتشار الفيروس مثل ما قلت
اجراءات غير مجديه تنظر بعين القلق
ما يحدث في الصين واعتقد الاجراءات التي
تقوم بها بعض الدول مثل فرنسا وايطاليا
واسبانيا بتعريض المسافرين القادمين من
الصين لفحص الكبديه اجراءات صحيحه جدا
شكرا